네 빌사남 미간다 강남구 신사동에 와
있습니다 오늘 가로 스킬 상권 분석과
여러분들한테 도움이 될 만한 정보들
많이 준비했으니까이 영상 끝까지 봐
주시면
[음악]
감사하겠습니다네 저는 지금 가로 스킬
대로변에 지금 카페에 좀 앉아 있는데
어 가로스 상황이 좀 되게 많이 안
좋은 거 같아요 저기 뒤에 보이는 저
건물도 원래 유명 프랜차이즈 업체가
거의 전층 다 쓰고 있었는데 지금
전층 다 공실입니다 한 진짜 개 건물
중에 거의 한 일곱개 한이 정도는 다
지금 공실인 거 같습니다 그래서
그만큼 지금 가로 스킬 상황이 되게
좀 많이 안 좋은 거 같아요 어
저도이 블록에 한 10년 정도
있었는데 어 이렇게 상황이 안 좋았던
적이 처음입니다 어 가로 스킬 상권에
대해서 여러분들한테 좀 간략하게
설명을 드리자면 여기는 원래 이제
아기자기한 삼정과 되게 좀 맛집들이
많이 좀 밀집되어 있었습니다 그러면서
이제 유동이가 좀 많아지기 시작했고
그럼으로 인해서 이제 대형 업체들이
좀 많이 들어오면서 임대료가 좀
천정부지로 좀 많이 올랐어요네
그러면서 기존에 있던 가로 스기
임차인이 이제이면 쪽으로 밀려나기
시작하면서 테로 스킬이랑 나로스킬
다로 스킬 생겨나기 시작했습니다
그래서 이제이면 지역의 상권이 좀
활성되지 있고 근데 가로 스킬 같은
경우에는 그런 대형 업체들이
들어오면서 좀 특색을 좀 많이 잃게
됐어요 오히려 지금은 가로
스킬보다는이면 쪽 상권이 오히려 더
활발하게 변했습니다 그래서 상권이 좀
죽기 시작했던 거는 한 2010년도
한 뭐 중후반 그러면서 지금 상권을
어떻게 보면은 구종 로데오의 좀 지금
뺏긴 상황이죠네 그래서 어떻게 보면
지금 가로 스킬 상권이 좀 최악의
시기이지 않나네 이렇게 보고
있습니다네 그럼 가로 스킬의 대표적인
건물인 애플 스토어도 어 과연 좀
영향을 받았을까요 어 제가 방금
지나오면서 봤는데 손님보다 직원이 더
많더라고요네 그 정도로 지금 애플
스토어도 좀 상황이 안 좋은 거
같습니다 어 애플 스토어 같은
경우에는 16년도에 어 임대차 계약을
체결해서 20년 장기 임대를
체결했어요 그래서 2036년까지 어
장기 임대차 계약을 했고 그리고 애플
스토어가 지금 신축하는 데까지 거의
한 중공 기간이 한 3년 정도
걸렸더라 그래서 그만큼 되게 공을
들여 가지고 어 신축한 그런
건물입니다 처음에 저도 기억나는게
애플 스토어 오픈할 때 진짜 줄서
있던 모습이 아직도 머릿속에
생생하군요 오늘 와서 또 보니까
직원이 더 많은 모습을 보면서 아
상권 좀 이렇게 변할 수 있구나 어
이런 거를 좀 생각하게 됐습니다
그리고 이제 많은 분들이 가로 스킬
투자를 생각해 볼 수 있는데 가로
스킬 기준으로 세로 스킬이 상권이
좋을까요 아니면 나로 스킬이 상권이
좋을까요 아니면 다로 스킬이 상권이
좋을까요네 그래서 정답을 말씀드리면
세로 스킬이 제일 좋습니다 왜냐하면
여러분들 지도를 보시면은 세로 스킬
같은 경우에는 이렇게 막힘 없이
이렇게 쫙쫙 뻗어 있어요 그리고
사람들이 다 이제 신사역 8번
출구에서 다
모이거나 가로 세로 스킬입니다 그래서
상이 세로 스킬이 나로스킬 다로
스킬보다는 훨씬 좋아요 그리고 나로
스이는 다로스지도 보시면은 좀
꾸불꾸불 돼 있고 언덕길이 있고
내리막길이 있고 막 그렇습니다 그래서
상권 확장이 좀 제한돼 있어요데
그리고 또 퀴즈 나와서 말씀드린 건데
1번 도로 2번 도로 3번 도로 중에
여러분들이 제일 상권이 좋을 것 같은
도로는 어딘지 한번 좀 맞춰 보시면
좋을 것 같습니다
정답은 3번 도로가 제일 좋습니다
로바로 이면에 넓은 도로가 상권이
제일 좋습니다 이것처럼 도로를 어떤
도로를 접하 따라서 상권이 달라지고
빌딩 가격이 달라지기도 합니다 뭐
같은 비슷한 지역에 있다라고 해서 다
똑같은게 아니라 이렇게 도로 하나에
따라서 어 상권이 좀 달라지기도
합니다 그래서 이런 부분 참고하셨다가
어 투자를 하시면 좋을 것 같습니다
이제 감이 예측 컨데 어 좀 가로스
상권 전망을 좀 예측을 하자면 예전
고정 로데오를 좀 비교해 보면 좋을
것 같아요 좀 여기 길 전체적으로
인대를 좀 낮추거나 어 뭔가 좀
합동해서 이쪽 가로수길 상권을 뭔가
살리려고 좀 많이 노력을 해야 될 거
같아요 근데 그게 단기간에 될 거
같진 않고 좀 그래도 몇 년이 걸릴
거 같습니다네 그래서 어 좀 단기간에
살아나긴 좀 어렵지만 조금 그런
노력들이 있으면 다시 살아나지
않을까네 좀 요렇게 예상을 하고 있고
지금이 최악인데 지금 뭔가 좀
괜찮은가 그게 뭐가 있다라고 하면
투자를 한다라고 하면 진짜 장기
플랜으로 투자를 하셔야 될 거
같습니다네 그래서 오늘은 어 가로
스킬 상권 분석과 여러분들한테 좀
빌딩 투자에 도움이 될 만한 어
내용들로 좀 말씀드렸는데 오늘 내용이
좀 마음에 드셨다면 여러분들 어
구독과 좋아요 눌러 주시면
감사하겠습니다 그리고 여러분들 혹시
만약에 내가이 상권에 대해서
궁금하다라고 하시는 상권이 있다라고
하면 댓글 남겨 주시면 어 저희가
검토해서 그쪽 지역에 있는 상권도 좀
분석해 드리도록 하겠습니다 그래서
오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요 다음
시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다 감사합니다
[음악]